simple howling motion is a very very the
reason why it's such a big deal I mean
it's a bit deceptive because it's not
just about motion in fact simple how I
wish it the equations that government
describe any phenomena whether it's
something that moves or something some
value or something like that that
fluctuates that's it
anything that fluctuates that goes back
and forth between two consistent values
right and I mean if you think about
motion that could be left right
it could be up down remember we're
thinking just that straight-line motion
and this is a particular clone of it but
there's not just motion like these other
things like um you know a heartbeat
that's that fluctuates right between
different phases okay it's still
governed by exactly the same equations
so let's think about I'm just gonna have
lots of examples down I said I said I'll
give you another one for free [ __ ]
life savings coins right bigger up and
down and up and down over ever again
give me some other ones what other kinds
of phenomena do we know about that
fluctuate in this way come on think
about it
that's a graph not a phenomenon what
does the graph describe what kinds of
things match this surely we can think of
some sound good so in fact any kind of
not just sound but like any kind of wave
right will I be you know it's going to
be sine waves right so any kind of
radiation all kinds of electromagnetic
radiation just travel in waves that's
how they look anything else the ticking
of a clock so
you could talk about standing waves I
suppose but then you're starting to get
into areas that I don't really know well
know much about I don't know things you
can think of temperature yeah of course
temperature during the day gets hotter
and then it gets cooler than it gets
hotter again and over and over
okay cool so what are the equations that
actually govern this well we're going to
start with time equations right
displacement velocity and acceleration
all in terms of x that's why they call
the time equations right so the idea is
that we want this kind of rhythmic shape
okay and I know some of you already
anticipate right the kind of shape that
we're talking about is either a sine
wave or a sine wave right so let's just
start with a simple one um think about
sine
how could we change you know some things
move very far up and down and some
things move just a little bit and some
things move frequently and other things
move really slow so what ways can we
oughta just a normal sign way to account
for those kinds of differences let's
take the up-and-down movement what would
I change about saying you know sine T
right that's what your sense of time how
would I change how far it goes up and
down it would be the coefficient right
at the front right so for example you
might see an a at the front a for fine
all right
every amplitude tells you the
extremities of the motions how far up
down left you just had a bad day today
minute I thought I've done left right
back forth whatever where she's going
what about frequency where what how
would i ulted that beam so you're gonna
have where where's the dope it's gonna
be constant where's it gonna go you're
gonna modify this T by multivision right
so it tends to be M
kind of you call it B you could call it
period f4 frequency whatever of intense
to being the convention okay now a side
empty your amplitude of a right
extremity positive extremity a negatives
from you negative a this is going to
control your frequency the period right
but how many reach of that you all met
already automatically do quite a few
things about this for instance where
does it start at time zero where is it
the answer is it's at the origin
wherever that is another way of saying
that is you're at your center of motion
right if my extremities are plus a and
negative a then the origin here is the
middle right the centre of Russia okay
but what if I don't want to start at the
center of motion lots of you know
different kinds of things they don't
just start at zero because we want them
to how I change that I'd have to have a
phase shift wouldn't right so in here I
would want to be off by some kind of
some kind of offset in there okay now I
used to think you've got this in terms
of angles so that's why it's called
alpha is a very common thing you'll see
there but I hope you see this is not an
angle it's not an angle what is it it's
a time it's a time right so I mean of
course it's a time because usually we're
like sine of 30 degrees or sine of PI on
six or whatever and we're used to that
argument in there being an angle right
but everything in here is it's not an
angle anymore
right we're thinking about motion
against time so alpha is a time that's a
bit meaning isn't it just out of
curiosity right we've already dealt with
alpha to the extreme ease of motion
we've dealt with phase what would be the
period of this function this particular
one how long would it take to go all the
way through it so I should get back to
the stop and repeat wouldn't it
that's a number worth recognizing
because very frequently you'll be asked
about what's a period of motion okay
good there you go no problems let's move
that to the next line
okay follow it next time I want to know
what the velocity is the relationship
between these equations as we go down is
differentiation right okay so what will
the derivative be your chain rule that
you okay so I'm gonna get that A's
hanging out the front drivet again sides
in and then sign of course turns into
quads good okay now we're going to think
about all of these in a second we're
gonna graph them and see what we can
gain from it but before we do that let's
just get the last equation conceives to
make sense as we're going through okay
differentiate one more time that you get
the acceleration which of course will
give you you're gonna have a negative
out the front because that cause will
turn into a negative sign right I'm
you're going to do chain rule again so
that end inside the argument comes out
again so I'm going to get a and squared
times I've gone back to sign she'll look
right yeah cool
what now let's graph these you're like
really graph these I know these switches
to death yes you do okay but we're not
that used to thinking of them in terms
of motion and there are going to be just
like with the tennis ball lots of
different insights that we can gain here
okay so even though I know we know
exactly what these look like I still
want you to graph them let's graph them
on three separate axes for now because
we want some actual values on this let's
just consider or consider super super
simple you know a equals one N equals
one alpha equals zero okay so that'll be
silent e cos T please graph it for me
let's do it from
let's do two two periods okay so I guess
this would be from yatta 14 seconds okay
let's draw that
I know it's simple but then let's draw
some conclusion like that and then the
title card runs of it anyway okay please
make a heading